- I think these might give me mom butt.
Hey cuties! Welcome to Ladylike.
- There's no reason why you
can't be comfy and cute.
- Today, we're going to try to style
the same pair of joggers...
- Four different ways.
- To show that anyone can rock anything.
- Let's play, Can I Wear That?
- [Voiceover] Joggers Edition.
- I think joggers are an
excuse to wear pajamas
in a social setting.
- Joggers are formal sweatpants.
- I'm pretty sure most
joggers have drawstring lace.
- I don't know what joggers are.
- My personal interpretation of joggers
is they're a happy marriage
between skinny jeans
and sweatpants.
They're casual, you can wear
them pretty much anywhere
and you can dress them up or down.
Big things that denote a jogger is
they're a little loose around the waist,
they can have a slight drop crotch
and the main thing is
they're tapered at the ankle.
I think as long as the girls are creative
and sort of embrace
what makes them unique,
then I think the jogger
is versatile enough
to blend in with whatever
clothes they accentuate it with.
- I think it's going to go well.
I think that I might win.
- I'm stressed about it.
- I fear that these pants will be loose
in the buttock region and
short in the ankle region.
- I think it will be a
challenge but I'm excited.
- Bring on the joggers.
(laughs) Oh my God.
- There's a lot of crotch.
- Super stretchy.
- I like the fabric, it's kind
of fun and ripply like water.
- All right, I'm going to put them on now.
- I love these.
I wish every single pant
was as comfortable as this.
- I could exercise in these if I wanted to
but I could also go out
in them if I wanted to.
- This is my problem.
- Like do I have mom jean butt?
- All right, I'm going
to try to style these.
Let's see what I can come across.
- I like wearing a lot of collared stuff
because it reminds me of
my good old uniform days.
- I like this a lot, it's kind
of like a 90's zipper thing.
- So, I've really been into ponchos.
- I love animals, especially elephants.
- It's a slit all the way up.
Hello.
- It looks like you
have your shit together
but you're also very comfortable.
- I think it's going to be pretty bad ass.
Pretty like dark meets light.
Pretty like devil meets angel.
- I look like someone who once upon a time
worked at Hot Topic and
now I have a real job
but I still remember my roots,
you know what I'm saying?
- My mom loves to describe me as edgy.
- I'm going to go with a little heel.
- I like these, I like this.
I like these pants.
What could go wrong?
- So this is me.
This is my outfit.
- I'm definitely feeling it.
I feel very easy breezy.
- I could totally buy a pair of joggers.
I could wear these every day,
these are so comfortable.
- I do like this little cape thing
because it effectively hides my behind.
I feel like I'm wearing pajama pants
and I'm getting away with
a dirty little secret.
- I could totally curl up
at home and watch a movie
or I could party in this.
- I'm not obsessed.
- Everyone should have a pair of these
because they're really cozy.
- Okay, so can you wear joggers?
I think the answer is yes.
- [All] Yes.
- A hundred percent.
- My ass is in fact jiggly but you know,
it's fine because it's disguised.
If I disguised the butt, the jiggly butt.
♫ Jiggly butt ♫